c---span to journalist Edward Humes
spent a year teaching writing at a
top-rated high school outside Los
Angeles he relates his experience in
school of dreams making the grade at a
top american high school this is just
under an hour
good evening thank you all for coming
out tonight my name is Michael link and
I'm the graphic designer here at
politics and prose and it is my absolute
pleasure to welcome you all to tonight's
event pretty soon after I started
working here and after I'd moved to DC
which wasn't too long ago there was an
article in The Washington City Paper
about the Marriott hospitality charter
school in DC and I read it and spent the
next probably two weeks solid fuming and
talking to everybody that could possibly
get my hands on about that
and when I found out that this book was
coming out it reminded me of another
author Bill McKibben who I'm a big fan
of when he wrote his book the end of
nature a lot of people criticized him
for putting out and laying out a
critique that he didn't provide any
positive examples of or anywhere to go
and when I first picked up this book I
found that this actually was where to go
it provides a lot of incredibly
incredibly positive constructive and
fascinating information about you know
what it is not only to be a high school
student today but also how to sort of
approach education in the society where
you know it's so concentrated on you
know while we're leaving no child behind
it's concentrating on failure at each
step of the way so without further ado
it is my distinct pleasure to welcome
tonight's author Pulitzer Prize winning
journalist and the author of the new
book School of Dreams Edward Humes
well thank you yeah appreciate that
introduction I you know when the first
morning I went back to high school I
realized I was in for a very different
ride from my original high school career
I just read um research for school of
dreams and I was ready to spend the year
at what is California's top-ranked
public school and and probably one of
the highest achieving public schools in
the country but you know here I was a
40-something guy sitting in the
classroom full of teenagers taking notes
asking way too many personal questions
and they were a little wary so it's time
to break the ice find something to talk
about and because I asked him about
summer vacation I figured beach fun
stuff
no first first girl I talked to I went
to economics camp you know two months of
economics can't next kid Oh calculus
immersion and he was really excited
about it calculus every day for two
months why so he have an entire year of
calculus out of the way so he could take
a second year during the school year and
what was left unsaid of course is that
for certain colleges the types that
these many of the kids at Whitney High
School in Cerritos California want to
attend two years of calculus with high
marks is you might as well be a god and
to get into those schools because after
all this is an era in which almost 40%
of the students in California who have
to take a high school exit exam could
not pass a basic math test sadly enough
that's at a sixth and seventh grade
level
these kids have have quite a different I
guess appeal you'd say to the to the
colleges they apply to so talking to the
kids about about summer vacation and
feeling a little you know embarrassed
about what I did wasn't anything like
that
I knew it was in high school as I
remembered it that the lives of high
achieving students not just at this
particular school but really all over
the country are an order of magnitude
more in ten
than previous generations and at least I
had a chance to do what parents can't do
which is to go to go to school with
their kids and hang out and find out
exactly what they're doing and I would
have considered myself I do consider
myself an overachieving student from
when I went to high school but I never
touched a cup of coffee in that time and
I can probably count on one finger all
the all-nighters I had to pull during my
career and while I did some modest
prepping for the SATs the idea of taking
them two or three times over would have
seen more like madness than mainstream
to my peers but certainly that's not the
case today
early in school of dreams I set up the
story this way I'll just read a little
excerpt anyone who spends time at
Whitney high can see it delivers
everything we could ask of a public
school hard work dedication academic
excellence a sense of mission all too
lacking in other schools a love of
learning a commitment to civic
involvement a safe haven and last but
not least in this era of accountability
and school budgets linked to performance
test scores to die for but also on
display are the unintended consequences
of building the public high school of
our dreams the creation of a new
generation of high achieving highly
pressured young people who fall into
despair not from failing a course but
from getting a B who may tackle subjects
and extracurricular activities not out
of love and interest but because of how
they will look on their college
applications who sometimes feel that
their lives will be over if they do not
get into one of the top colleges in the
country who sometimes feel compelled to
cheat or to take stimulates in order to
keep up with large schedules and larger
expectations and who retake their
grueling SATs even after scoring in the
1500s putting them in the top 99 percent
of students why because an extra 10 or
20 points might make the difference
between receiving in the mail the thick
welcome to Yale University envelope
crammed with orientation materials and
the horrifyingly thin dear applicant we
regret to inform you envelope
with just one piece of paper inside the
kids of Widney did not give up sizable
parts of their childhood most others
take for granted in order to get the
thin envelope thick and thin that's what
it all comes down to in the end
kosha the economics camp girl observes
morosely six years of insanely hard work
boils down to peering inside your
mailbox and shuttering or celebrating at
the size of an envelope knowing the
outcome before you even open the missive
in your quivering hands this is an event
koushin her fellow seniors are
anticipating with delicious horrible
fear this year the culmination of six
long wonderful grueling years
forget Generation X kosha belongs to
Generation stressed around here a senior
named Tony says with a murse mirthless
laugh while waiting in line at Starbucks
behind the entire pep squad for is the
magic number we all want 4.0 grade point
averages we all get by on four hours
sleep and it can take four big lattes
just to get through the day now Tony's
exaggerating a little bit when he said
that he's a funny guy but only to a
point
the students really would complain all
the time like teenagers so of course
they complained all the time about the
workload and the stress the all-nighters
they'd have to pull but the surprise
surprised me with just when I'm thinking
this is too much already I'd ask them
why do they stick it out you could go to
the high school down the street and have
a much easier time of it and be one of
the top students there and they seem
surprised I even asked oh we wouldn't
want to go anywhere else this is like a
second home for us
we feel safe here it's okay to be smart
here it wasn't like that at our last
school it's cool to be smart here how
many other high schools have you heard
we're one of the most popular kids on
campus the captain of the basketball
team also gets a perfect 1600 on his
SATs and it's true for for all the hard
work and all the complaining about a
majority of the students I met at this
school seem to love and appreciate the
school you can see it at the end of each
day after the last class ends it does
not turn into a ghost town they're still
hanging out there sprawled out on the
carpeting in the hall socializing doing
their homework
decompressing the school stays open for
as long as the students want to stay
there now it's interesting I've gotten
two distinctly different reactions when
I talk about the school and and its
rigorous environment the long hours the
many hours of homework the kids get
there's there's one set of people who
read about this or hear me talk and they
don't care about the stress so much or
the extra homework or the the sleepless
nights three or four times a month their
reaction to sign me up you know this is
this is what's drawing families from
other school districts other cities even
other parts of of the world to this
public school campus with its very
modest facilities and modest budget you
know though the community of Cerritos is
I'd have to call it geographically
unfashionable and I'm sure they'll have
to forgive me for that
Realtors advertise homes for sale there
all over the world Seoul Taiwan Hongkong
people are making home purchases in
Surrey to us to get into the school and
the school has remade the demographics
of this community now at the other
extreme some people express horror when
they hear about the lives of students at
Whitney and part of that is because I
tell all kinds of stories in the book
about the lives of the the kids I met
there's one young woman Cecilia in
particular that people always bring up
she's just a wonderful kid fantastic
artist extremely talented but her
parents did not agree with her desire to
pursue art as as a course of study they
wanted something more practical and one
evening one thing led to another and her
portfolio ended up hurled in the street
an entire year's worth of worth being
run over by car several times before she
was permitted to pick it up and people
here
terrible things like that and say the
school is too much kids should not have
to give up being kids to be educated
they shouldn't have such pressure
schools are about building a whole
person not just test taking machines
and it's hard to disagree with that and
this horror reaction is often
accompanied by a kind of dismissal of
the school success and of other
successful schools as an aberration
Whitney and places like it the Thomas
Jefferson's and Stuyvesant's in New York
Boston Latins they offer little in the
way of lessons that can be applied to
public schools in general this point of
view holds and there's a variety of
reasons that are suggested for this
state cherry-picked the best students or
their parents are more involved or they
have entrance requirements they're
magnet schools they have a lot of Asian
American students the regions are legion
y a Whitney's success can't be
replicated at most other schools this
point of view holds and I I find this a
little disturbing fascinating and
disturbing because I agree that
certainly some of the parents I met of
these high achieving kids need to need
to chill out you know they are living
vicariously through their students
although I didn't find that to be the
majority and indeed most of the parents
they although intensely involved in the
education of their students are much
more moderate than then then poor
Cecilia's parents but I really have to
ask when you get beyond those kinds of
concerns can it really be true that the
top school in all of California which
sends ninety nine and a half percent of
their students to college has has
nothing to offer in the debate about how
to make schools more successful I spend
enough time there and I started
wondering do we is it really true that
schools need to exist to build a whole
person the people wouldn't say that's
what their families are for their
churches their social organizations
their synagogues the institutions
outside of school and that they wanted
academics to be the focus of their
schools shouldn't schools be rigorous
shouldn't parents be more involved than
the average in a children's in their
children's education and why shouldn't
getting a great education be demanding
and demand a great deal of students
teachers and parents the idea that that
kind of priority would be seen
an aberration strange to me we live in
an era and Michael said this so well the
the focus is on failure with our schools
the vast majority of official
pronouncements from the White House on
down as well as the bulk of media
reports about our schools concern
themselves with public education failure
with obsessive testing finger-pointing
at schools that fail to to measure up to
the standards set by those tests and
then followed by a lowering of the bar
in order to make those same schools
appear to be more successful
public school success meanwhile is the
most underreported story around which is
one reason why I tackle this book and
one reason why I'm fascinated by the
reactions of parents who express the
fear of schools like Whitney I'll be
interested to hear what you what's your
reaction to that is because the kids I
got to know talk about their former
schools the ones they experienced before
they came to Whitney in much more
negative turns and they ever used to
describe the school they're in now they
say the pressure there from their peers
was to not study to not be too smart
because they're it's not the road to
popularity or a romance or coolness or
success so you know it's pick your
pressure your kids are going to get it
one way or another we live in an era the
Department of Commerce will tell you
this in which the average American
household spends more on haircare
products video rentals and restaurant
meals than on education and reading the
average American school child spends
these are the latest figures I could
find 78 minutes a week reading 102
minutes on homework and study and 12
hours a week watching television those
are our priorities asking schools where
children spend only 10% of their time to
compensate for this set of priorities is
asking a great deal the trick is to do
what places like Whitney have done
change the priorities change the culture
of the school of the parents and can you
imagine for a minute where we would be
if the average American household if we
if there was some sort of
campaign on the order of the drunk
driving campaigns of the 80s or the
anti-littering campaigns of the 60s
remember iron eyes Cody with a leathered
face of my tears community people
stopped throwing trash on the highway
they stopped driving without a
designated driver they changed their
behavior you can imagine if something
like that were undertaken to persuade
Americans to change their priorities to
read maybe change that percentage so the
12 hours are not spent watching
television but spent on reading on
education I think that would have more
of an impact than a thousand high-stakes
tests or a century of No Child Left
Behind measures all this came into focus
for me during this wonderful moment I
didn't know was gonna happen when I when
I first started going to Whitney when
Neil Bush came to the school the the
president's little brother who has a
educational software company it was a
wonderful moment he had generously
donated a computer program his company
makes the school for it for a tryout and
basically what it does I think I think
this is a fair summary it it turns
subjects such as history into games and
songs and other easily digested new
media and he he came after the the kids
had tried and he told he described his
vision for four schools which he saw
including the one he was principal of
the day at Whitney that schools are like
prisons that force-feed boring and
irrelevant subjects like calculus to
students and he wanted to change all
that
and he was flabbergasted when a roomful
of teenagers responded no they didn't
think education should be an effortless
entertainment that learning should be
challenging and he just not encountered
students quite like this and I'll just
read you a little bit from the from that
scene I don't think we're over schooled
kosha says again this is the young lady
who went to economics camp I hear
students say oh math is boring
this or that subject is boring so I
don't want to do it and I say that's an
excuse a crutch a student should want to
learn about everything that's what we're
here for
wishes again taken by surprise only when
she mentions the study of calculus does
Busch sense an opening and he interrupts
seizing on what he perceives to be a
flaw in her argument no one really wants
to study calculus he says triumphantly
calling it a prime example of being
forced to study something a kid thinks
is terribly useless and obscure I like
calculus kosha answers looking him in
the eye it instills critical thinking
it's definitely a challenge but it
forces you to think in creative ways
some students may think school should be
a cakewalk that it shouldn't be hard
that you should play all day but that's
not the way to excellence that's an
interesting defense of what I consider
to be a broken system Bush says
dismissively but several other students
jump in to support coach's point and one
eye after another they decry the notion
they sense is lurking behind his
criticisms the idea that school should
be made easier and more entertaining the
problem as they see it isn't that school
is too boring or too hard but that too
many young people are unwilling to work
and extend themselves to master
difficult subjects too many kids and
parents and teachers have low
expectations they say they should be
urged to reach higher not settle for
Less kosha and the other Whitney
students argue but I truly believe there
is a boundary to teaching kids core
knowledge critical skills Bush argues
his tone is almost pleading now as he
finds himself alone pitted against six
kids with near-perfect SATs and a love
for higher math and no support from the
other adults in the room once you get to
high school you have special interests
evolving I don't see what's wrong and
allowing kids to pursue their interests
why must we continue to cram this other
stuff down their throats well you would
just have apprenticeships then instead
of high school kosha says so what's
wrong with that Bush responds because it
abandons the whole notion of building an
entirely educated person before he can
answer that to more seniors jump up we
don't have the life experiences to make
those decisions Tara says we're not
ready to decide what we're interested in
Angela adds we need to learn more that's
why we go to college the principal leans
over and whispers he's losing the
argument because the system works for
these kids really it works for most kids
not just at Whitney but he's focused on
the failure and a few Christopher
the principle is crystallized not just
Bush's philosophy but the whole national
debate on the future of public education
and the unbridgeable chasm that
separates those who are interested in
what's working and those who are fixated
on what's not Bush has built a computer
program along with an entire worldview
around the notion that the whole
educational system is broken and he
appears confounded by a school that
succeeds and students who excel so I'd
like to end my blabbing on that note and
take some questions or get some
discussion going see what you think yes
Whitney can teach other public schools
or the bushes in general okay well I
think there's a few things one is that
the school does have a very focused
mission academics first and everything
else takes second place so that they
have the same kinds of activities sports
cheer banned art that other schools do
but all of it is contingent upon a
certain level of performance in classes
and if you dip below that then you don't
have access to it the second thing is
you have incredibly involved parents
kids will tell you sometimes too
involved but one thing they do is they
reinforce the priorities that the school
sets so if the homework isn't getting
done or there's a problem it's not just
the school cracking down the parents say
okay
driving privileges going until you turn
it around so there's that kind of
synergy that the parents and the school
have with one another a third really
critical thing as the the age in which
the kids begin this this college prep
public school environment they come in
at age 11 and 12 and begin a very
rigorous academic program not all the
kids are ready for that and another
strength of the school is the use of the
older students as mentors and tutors for
some of the incoming 7th
I really need to get acquainted and
brought up to that kind of rigorous
academic environment it's interesting
and I talked about this a little bit and
towards the end of the book there's a
school in Los Angeles called accelerated
it's a charter public school and it
embraces many of the same philosophies
that Whitney does with younger students
and what's unusual about it is that it
has a longer school day very rigorous
curriculum and one entrance requirement
that the parents who send their children
there must agree to volunteer 30 hours a
year in the school that's the only
requirement to get in other than you
live in the neighborhood where the
school is located which is South Central
Los Angeles one of the most economically
devastated urban areas in the country
and a place where historically the the
students in the neighborhood where the
school is located have just the lowest
test scores in the state this particular
school just by selecting for more
involved parents has test scores that
average hundreds of points higher than
the surrounding schools with basically
the same population they have 5,000
people parents lined up waiting to get
their kids in I mentioned that because
it I think it's that kind of parental
involvement in schools is incredibly
powerful and something that we're not
even beginning to tap into yes I would
call a culture of continuity or a common
commitment and we know from research in
education that yes that works there are
many things that would make that work
but without the community and the
working together in supporting all this
business of pouring you know things into
the school and trying to make that work
alone if it doesn't and so from what I
think what you have described as I said
is a culture that you've got the school
students the parents everybody is
working together I'm sure there are a
lot of glitches I'm not saying it's
ideal but that's what that's one of the
things that will make this work yes look
at the other communities look at so many
communities in the United States that
they say absolutely the culture of the
school the culture of high expectations
is and the community and families
embracing it is it is all working
together and it is it is not perfect
absolutely there's much to be worked out
but it really did I didn't go in
thinking that this school would be a
model for all of public education
because it does select the top students
in its district it has some innate
advantages that other schools aren't
going to have and yet some of the things
many of the the core philosophy of the
school could apply to almost any other
public school if you can persuade the
community and parents to get involved
you know this school is fascinating
evolution it started out as a vocational
school its claim to fame was a chef's
Training Institute had served blue-plate
specials to the community a favorite for
the bachelor teachers and the local
business for our steak there's is in the
mid 70s and it tried to do a little bit
everything was an alternative school it
was an Adult Learning Center you know
you can learn floral arranging there it
didn't have a complete academic
curriculum and it couldn't attract
enough students it was about to be
closed and the principal and the
teachers and literally gathered around
the kitchen table and brainstorm at what
can we do to transform the school it
will give that what will give parents
something that they want and then is now
the concern was what it always is in
America the schools aren't as good as
they used to be and that's what we
always think
and this was just before the Reagan
administration published a
groundbreaking report that declared our
schools in such dire shape it was a
matter of national security and the name
of that report eludes me I'm sure
someone out here could could could tell
me but a nation at risk exactly it was
in the air just leading up to that and
what was what the principal was quite a
visionary and his teachers decided was
what we really need is to do what
private schools have been doing for
years for public school parents and that
is help our kids get into the best
colleges in the country and they came up
with an idea for this academic magnet
school they started out taking just
about anybody who would come they did
have a test that the teachers created on
their own they were looking for
something that you probably couldn't
measure so well with a standardized test
they were looking for more adventurous
kinds of students who would help them
build the school from the ground up they
had no money they were using the same
teachers they and who were still at the
school and large numbers who were
teaching the floral arranging teacher
became a math teacher and the adult
learning teacher who taught ceramics to
adults is now and still is the art
teacher who's fabulous but they they
took what they had they changed their
mission the principal had a following
from his previous post as an elementary
school principal and got kids to come
and crazy thing you have more rigorous
classes you tell kids at 11 and 12 that
they're gonna go to a great college and
you tell them you're also going to apply
not just to the State University which
you are going to apply to Ivy League
schools and you are going to apply to
private schools and we're gonna help you
do that and the funny thing is this kids
got and the school got better and better
their test scores got higher and higher
and and building on that very bare-bones
structure the school became one of the
the highest in terms of test scores in
the state and began attracting the top
students in its school district
the previous hands-on policy of the the
school district came to an end at that
point and they and they began a more
rigid kind of standardized testing to
admit students there and and now I think
one on paper the students there are more
high achieving than ever before but what
they there is a greater emphasis on test
taking and it used to be and and some of
the old timers at the school worried
about that but there's no question that
the this school transformed itself in a
very remarkable way from at the
community level yes sir if you had a
chance to talk to the teachers
themselves and how many of them had
advanced degrees and what was the
variety of pedagogy amongst them I would
imagine there was a there was quite a
lot of different teaching styles oh yes
yes and what I chose the way I chose to
do this book and it's the way I've done
my previous book is is to really tell
stories about the kids about the
teachers and I put together a roster I
went to class every day in the same
classes every day with the same kids and
the same teachers and I tried to get as
broad a range of the styles of teaching
as as I could a couple of the teachers
actually made me do the work and take
the test the art teacher was one some
used the kids know and the styles went
from one of the most beloved teachers at
the school who teaches Advanced
Placement in honors history a guy named
Dave Bohannon who is a traditionalist in
every sense of the word will not touch
computers you know as he says they'll
pride the 3x5 cards out of my cold dead
fingers and that's how he teaches his
course and they those cars look like
they date by a while but he knows his
subject he knows how to engage kids in
it's a stand up and lecture model and
then discuss and this was the year of my
school yard was the year of 9/11 and I
saw him turn
the current events of the day into
discussions of our country's history in
a way well I can only wish I had had a
history teacher like that in my he he
was beloved by the students and I also
found out something in his course a
little off with your question that this
class that is most favored by college
admissions or advanced placement classes
this college level classes that are at
the most rigorous course of study many
of the students felt like their
educational experience in them was not
as fulfilling and as in-depth as those
that other students experience then the
next rung of classes the honors class
where there was more time to spend on
the subject and and more ability to go
off on tangents when when the subject
matter led them to that the whereas the
advanced placement courses always have
to teach to the test and they're
excellent classes but they're very wide
not so deep so it's another example I
thought where our focus on testing
doesn't always lead us in the best and
most productive direction now other
teachers there are much more
non-traditional the physics teacher
there oh I also spent I spent a lot of
time in his class revealing my own
inadequacies in that field but he was a
former oil company executive who then
had a successful acting career in in
commercials but was unfulfilled by that
and found his true calling and in
teaching and he worries a lot about the
difference between being a great test
taker and a great learner and he spends
a lot of time coming up with independent
projects that give chances to kids who
excel in other ways to to be at the top
and to also show kids who have mastered
the art of cramming and and then taking
the test and doing rate that they're the
real world may offer different and and
value different skills and abilities so
his classroom was always a lively place
but I would say the faculty is not a
group of stars the faculty resembles
that of most public schools you have
some really great teachers you have some
people who you wish would never enter a
classroom again and then you have the
the vast in-between you said that
Whitney changed the priorities and made
education a priority but it also seems
like what needs changed the community
you've got new people coming in and want
to send their schools there and same
thing with your example in LA you've got
one school that's catering to a small
group of people who value education but
it's not applicable across the whole
community and you just you haven't
convinced me yet that the success of
Whitney can be duplicated in all schools
and in all communities without
physically changing the communities well
I well I would agree that given what
what are with the average American
households Pryor is that is is a hue is
huge what I think is true also though is
that this school I described in in South
Central the accelerated school and
Whitney yes they have brought new people
to the community but they also have
convinced many people that they needed
to change their priors who live in that
community I mean there's not five
thousand people did not move to South
Central Los Angeles because of this
school these are residents in community
who have seen what that school can do
for their children and who have changed
their minds about what their priorities
ought to be but it would be way over
simplistic to say yes we can just
announce here's a new school that has
rigor and a new set of priorities and
expect everyone to just fall into into
place behind it I think
takes a lot more than that but I feel
strongly that the culture of this school
is something that can and should be
replicated and more widely and does not
need to be limited to the highest
achieving students can I do as a teacher
to change the priorities and my students
and with their families well that is the
elixir right well what I see what I see
what works at Whitney what I saw was
very open lines of communication between
the administration of the school between
the teachers and the parents you know
nobody at Whitney how much their kids
are intercepting communications from the
school no parent at Whitney we'll find
out on report card day that their kid
has a problem they will get a note
telling them that a note is coming that
their child is at risk of not passing a
course you know there's you do not slip
through the cracks at this school it's
just it has a thousand students but it
feels like a small school they have
three grade-level advisers that are
counselors for the kids they see the
kids on a regular basis not just when
they're in crisis but to stay abreast of
what's going on in their lives
parents are made to feel welcome at this
school and invited to participate in the
school in a variety of ways and that's
not all that comment on some of our
campuses where parents are made to feel
unwelcome so I guess to answer your
question how do you how do you start to
change a school I think that is hugely
important the communication the
involvement I should preface my question
by admitting that I am in fact a Whitney
graduate and I would be very interested
to hear your impressions of racial
issues at Whitney it's not discussed
much in the book but I remember it as
being I remember them as being more
prevalent during my time there and I
remember specifically the decision to
move away from the quotas yes in
admissions which is discussed but if you
would expand a little further
let me ask when did you attend thanks
well for people who aren't familiar with
with this region of Los Angeles the
school district in which Whitney is
located it is a very diverse area of Los
Angeles the city of Cerritos which is
one of several municipalities in the
school district is one of I think five
may now be six cities in California that
have a majority of asian-americans as
they're in their demographics and
Whitney high school has been a huge
factor in altering the demographics of
the community there's been a multiple
waves of immigrants from primarily from
Asian countries in India and the
Philippines that were attracted in part
because of the of this program at this
school I found in my time there that the
campus was remarkably harmonious you
know other schools in Los Angeles area
that I visited have campuses that are
self segregated you know you go out
particularly at lunch and you see
homogeneous groups of different ethnic
and racial groups not you know as if
there's an invisible wall erected and
it's really the first time you visit the
I visited a campus there I was just
struck by it
oh yeah well he over here is this group
over here somebody was showing me around
and giving me the as if it was normal
we at Whitney I didn't see that I saw
much more at least today it may have
been different ten years ago but I
didn't see those kinds of divisions I
saw kids who are
from other joint joining the the
Filipino cultural Club who aren't
Filipinos and and the Chinese Club had
kids had white kids in it you know it
was it was a very surprisingly happy mix
now there was a time prior to to being
made illegal I guess that there was an
affirmative action a quota plan for
having set numbers of different ethnic
groups admitted to the school that ended
and now there's a system of geographic
preferences the top 20% of students as
measured by the annual tests that the
state of California gives from each
elementary school in the district are
invited to attend
Witney and because the schools are quite
distinct in in their racial and ethnic
populations
I guess this the school administration
the district administration feels they
can assure some level of diversity that
way as it happens if you look at the
demographics of the school the Asian
American population is somewhat slightly
over-represented on the campus at
Whitney the Caucasian population is just
exactly the percentage of the district
and african-americans and Latino kids
are somewhat underrepresented in the
student body at Whitney and that's
that's a bit troubling but because it's
a geographic preference there's all
kinds of gaming going on parents move
into elementary school areas where they
feel they have the best chance of
getting their kids into Whitney and
that's I don't know what they're gonna
do about over if they can do anything
about that
for the school there's an average and
I'm wondering about how the people that
are below average at the school is yes
is the question that how do students at
this school who are sort of at the
bottom get by is it well I think that's
what happens is of course you know you
have a school of high it's primarily
high I mean if you take the college
track population of a comprehensive high
school and put it alone you know just
have them in a school by themselves
that's kind of what you're looking at
here but that's still going to be
arranged
yes exactly yeah I I have to talk about
this young woman Cecilia I met I
mentioned who is an artist it's also
quite an excellent student certainly not
at the top student though and and this
is something that that was a little sad
to see because here's a kid who does
well in her classes A's and B's
excellent SAT scores but certainly not
than you know at the very pinnacle and
she thinks she's stupid you know she's
talking to her counselor and saying oh
well I'm pretty average of course she's
got parents who are also making her feel
this way I I just don't really think I'd
do anything very well and it was really
hard to listen and then her counselors
trying to say whoa wait a minute no
you're a gear a governor's scholar
you're national merit you're all these
great things no no I'm just I'm just
average because she is comparing herself
to two kids who are getting 4.0 or you
know four point five s or whatever even
whatever they're capable of and getting
these these insane SAT scores what
happens interesting is another student
who I'd put in that same category Angela
she's the first person you meet in this
book she had a very hard year and I
really I got to know her she said ah you
see I had a long talk with her should
she really tell her stole
and she said yes I want to tell my story
and her parents read the book and didn't
talk to her for a week and and I have
it's really upset by this she said no no
it's okay the week's over and they're
talking to me and we're actually talking
about these these things that we needed
to talk about that we never could before
so so that's good
but Angela was also in that category but
she felt like you know I don't test well
I feel like I know things but it doesn't
show I'm so she felt very inadequate and
now she's she's in college she's at
University of California campus it's
just gosh I that works so much easier
now I'm doing so well I I had no idea I
was as prepared as I was the work was
nothing like what I had in high school
so she ended up feeling like it was all
worthwhile
she's in her second year of college and
is doing really well I just saw her the
parents are talking to her so I
mission accomplished yes where each
student can progress as high a level as
he is possible pan and that'd be taken
care of within the school system where
they can achieve as much as they can I
mean or is that everything and a level
on the box where it gets hairy here
because the teacher has it all set up
and arranged oh no did the one thing
this the school does not put any limits
on at Whitney high school you can go go
as high as you want to go there's I met
young people there in their senior year
who were taking five Advanced Placement
college-level courses in a school year
which is I don't think a very helpful
load but some of them we're pulling it
off and it's like they can go they can
get their college degree in three years
instead of four if you if you're willing
to put in that kind of work
I don't think they had much of a life
outside of their school work but that
was a choice that they were they were
making you don't have to have that
intense a
career at this school in order to do
well but that that option is available
to you you can also the schools big on
encouraging students to take actual
on-campus college courses Community
College course they have a partnership
with a local community college so that
off school classes that I learn offered
at on the high school campus are
available so it's it's the sky's the
limit yes
know what that was interested the
question is what what role did the
school board and the community have in
the creation of the school well I as I
said the school was really a fait
accompli over the summer you know
instead of it being closed down the
principal had reopened with with a whole
new student body and and this academic
magnet program the school board took a
hands-off policy with it at first and
just sort of sat back and year-to-year
said all right we'll let you live for
another year and see what happens it's
funny because the kids who go there now
had no idea their school had such humble
beginnings they were very surprised when
I told them about this wide the orange
vinyl booths and the teachers lounge
which used to be the chef's training or
should have given away the but after a
time when the school began to attract
more students and more the top students
in the community the pressure began to
come from the other high schools that
previously had been at the top of the
heap and there was actually a petition
drive by the teachers at those schools
to close down Whitney so that they could
get their students back in their college
prep programs and it was a huge battle
and the school was almost closed at one
point the school board ended up not
doing that but that was when the the
testing changed and they went to the
more the standardized test system and
then there was a proposal to get rid of
the seventh and eighth grade component
and just make it a senior high school
and put more students in there which the
there's the the principal and the staff
again thought would be disastrous
because there the whole program is based
on having most of the students begin the
process at an at a young age but the
parents are the ones that rallied to
support the school and turned out in
great numbers at the school board
meetings and angry moms at the
microphone is not you know as a
politician's worst nightmare so the
school board
ended up preserving the program pretty
much as it as it was conceived and it
seems like the pressure is coming from
the kids and from the parents as well we
come from a very similar magnet school
in Northern Virginia called Thomas
Jefferson High School oh it is but we
have very so many similarities it's
unbelievable
but I wonder how this school Whitney was
able to or are they able to broaden the
horizons do they have a big game plan
that they are working on to try and get
the families to look beyond that trio of
schools so so your question is does does
Whitney have a have a program to
persuade kids to look beyond the the a
list colleges and universities yes but
what an uphill battle I mean the college
admissions process is an arms race now
and one thing that happened I'll dig
wrestle a little bit that was really
distressing to the students is here the
four years kids had been building their
college resumes with all the activities
they could possibly load up to because
the watchword was you have to be a
well-rounded student you have to be a
well-rounded person so they you know
they were signing up for this volunteer
opportunity this sports thing I don't
really like soccer but I'm gonna play
and in this the college counselors began
making the rounds at the be near the
beginning of the school year in which I
was there saying well we got some good
news and some bad news and it turned out
that the watchword wasn't well-rounded
anymore the watchword was you must have
a passion so instead of a zillion
activities there should be one or two
things that you pursue avidly and with
great dedication and that's what the
college's really want now and the look
of betrayal on the own some of these
kids faces like why did I do all this
and I guess there was a good lesson
there because the answer is they
shouldn't
doing all this stuff just to please some
idea of a college admissions perfect
person and I suppose it's a healthy
thing now that there's a difference
emphasis but I listen to these same
counselors talk to the kids about well
you know there's three thousand three
hundred colleges and universities and
Community Schools and in the country
many of which you've never heard of but
which offer programs that might be just
what you need or maybe the tops in their
field and they're not necessarily the 50
top schools on the US news list or
whatever it is that you're looking at
and you really need to widen your
horizons and a few of the kids seem like
they were hearing it but most of the
kids most of the parents want the name
brands for a variety of reasons that's
where they're gonna apply and very hard
to convince them otherwise and they're
bringing in people from those schools
and trying to broaden the horizons but I
think they've got an uphill battle
because I think the priorities of a lot
of our students are different too if you
look at that they do an annual poll of
incoming freshmen or what do you hope to
gain most from from your college
experience and over the years it would
range from you know I want to make make
the world better to you know to want a
great career the number one answer now
for the last couple years and this is
for the first time since they've been
taking the survey is I want to make the
most money possible and I think it's
only gonna get harder because if that's
really the priority harder to persuade
our young people that they should take a
chance on when their college choices I'd
like to see what what's your what Thomas
Jefferson is doing to try and turn that
around
I showed them the book and children so
that means almost the entire class it's
a different evening I think there we
were talking about the feeling in your
book I think of the population in
themselves obviously we also when the
girl mentioned the racial issues that's
a big love to visit that school is
symptom well yeah that's actually you
bring up a really interesting issue I
don't know if I could I could go back to
high school for another year but one
thing that one reason I chose this
campus is because they're doing so much
with so little you know the they get
less money per student at this school
than any of the surrounding schools in
the area we're talking six thousand
dollars a year per student and they they
nevertheless one of the top schools in
the country and I really wanted to
mention that because it shows that it's
not necessarily about money when you're
talking about improving schools
Edward Humes is a Pulitzer prize-winning
journalist and author of several books
including school of dreams making the
grade at a top american high school it's
published by Harcourt online at Harcourt
books com